قبل أسبوع تحدثنا مع
امرأة سودانية باسم داليا عبدالمنعم
في الوقت الذي كانت فيه في الخرطوم
خائفة بالتأكيد ولكن غير متأكدة مما إذا كان
يجب أن تغادر اليوم ، علمنا أن
داليا وعائلتها الآن بأمان في
بورتسودان ولكن  رحلة مدتها 26 ساعة كانت
بالتأكيد مروعة
أصيب منزلنا بصاروخ ولم ينطلق الصاروخ ، بل
اخترق السقف فقط ونحن
نعتقد أنه لا يزال موجودًا في المنزل
لذا لم يعد خيارًا آمنًا.
اضطررنا إلى الخروج ،
لذلك تمكن بعض الأصدقاء من العائلة من
إجلائنا من منزلنا في
اليوم التالي لأنه في اليوم الذي
أصاب فيه الصاروخ حرفياً ، كان هناك جنود في جميع
أنحاء مربعنا ، استولوا على
منزل خلفنا واستولوا على منزل
آخر.  بناء لذلك لم نتمكن من التحرك وقد قاموا
أيضًا
بتجريد سياراتنا وأخذوا
بنزيننا وحاولوا إشعال الرهان على
السيارات حتى أتلفوها لذا
لم نتمكن من المغادرة كنا عالقين ولكن هذين
الرجلين اتصلوا بنا للتو  كأننا
قادمون غدًا لاصطحابك
ونأخذك إلى مكان آمن وهذا
ما فعلوه في مخاطرة كبيرة لأنفسهم
لأنه كان من الأسهل المغادرة من
الذهاب إلى منطقتنا ثم المغادرة مرة أخرى
لكنهم لم يفعلوا  ومن أجل ذلك ، أنا
مدين لهم إلى الأبد ،
أشكر الله على النهاية السعيدة
هناك ، وقالت إنها
بالتأكيد نعمة أن تكون خارج
الرسوم المتحركة لكنها قلقة بشأن
أولئك الذين لا يستطيعون الفرار.